hi I'm Victor M Sweeney licensed
mortician we're here at cormo funeral
service come on
[Music]
in we've been given unprecedented access
to the whole funeral home we're going to
go into the prep room where we embal and
prepare bodies normally uh if a person
from the outside like yourself wanted to
go into the prep room they wouldn't be
allowed we've been given special access
today from the Department of Health and
we're going to look at caskets earns
that kind of stuff we're going to get to
see the Funeral Chapel and then we'll
also get to take a tour of the hearse
see how that works with us today is Sean
Victor thanks for having me here I
really appreciate it death can be kind
of scary there's a lot of things about
our our field that are unknown I'm
excited for you to bring those answers
to everyone today first we're going to
go inside the prep
room why don't you come with me and I'll
show you what we
do so here we are in the prep room the
room where we do all the embalming
embalming is meant to sanitize and
preserve bodies as well as provide some
level of restoration so for instance if
someone is grievously injured we can
kind of work to reconstruct them um in
addition to making sure that their body
holds up for maybe the week that we have
in between the time when they die and
the time when we have the funeral in
this Funeral Home the prep room is off
of the garage I don't want to be uh
bringing cots with bodies on them up or
downstairs or through the whole funeral
home to get them here cuz then we can go
right from the van to the room where the
magic
happens we've taken our dummy Mike from
the back of the van and now we are ready
for the EMB baling every time time you
prepare a body you kind of start from
zero so you're going to do inventory
you're going to look them over you're
going to make sure that you know
everything about their condition and
then adjust your embalming processes
accordingly in a normal situation I'm
covered from head to toe with personal
protective equipment and that's mainly
to keep me safe when I'm dealing with
blood and pathogens I'm also dealing
with embalming fluids uh so these are
things that keep bodies preserved and
sanitized and a lot of these contain Al
Ides these are actually toxic chemicals
every prep room is going to have
ventilation it's going to have from
Malahide level monitoring all these
things are in place to keep me safe and
uh to make sure that we don't infect our
public spaces with what we have to do
here in
[Music]
private one of the first steps of
embalming is is setting the features so
making the face into a natural
expression these are called eye caps
sometimes when people die their eyes are
open and we can position the eyelids and
have them stay that way we use this
device called the needle injector that
actually punches these sharp Brads into
the upper and lower jaw kind of keep it
in place they'll stay that
[Music]
way the next part of embalming after we
set those features is we're going to do
what's called arterial embalming so
we're going to gain access to the
arteries and then that's how we're going
to use our embalming machine to pump
fluids
[Music]
in so there are three different kinds of
fluids that embalmer use when preparing
a body the first arterial Solutions are
going to be fixatives so they're going
to sanitize the body they're going to
preserve it and they're going to fix it
into place other fluids are what we call
co- injection or accessory fluids co-
injections might add fluid to tissue
they might draw fluid out they'll add
color sometimes maybe a rosiness is
helpful and then we have other fluids
that uh are really good at preventing
certain types of
decomposition probably the most common
place for a funeral director to gain
access to an artery is right up here in
the neck and that is called the coted
artery let's say you choose not to raise
the coted artery you can actually embalm
a whole body right here from the leg so
the femoral artery is one of the largest
arteries that we have access to if you
push fluid up you can open the
corresponding and then the blood will
drain out and arteries are interesting
because they're very rubbery think like
a like a tube rubber band and so when we
put high pressure into them with the
embalming machine they're able to
withstand that the fluid just goes right
into the
[Music]
body so this tank here is the embalming
machine and this tube goes right down
the artery and then is going to shoot
fluid in at a high pressure in order to
circulate that fluid through while
pushing out the blood that's been
pooling in the Venus
system so this will actually simulate
something of a heartbeat so if you have
large clots that are stuck in a Venus
system you can pulse the fluid through
at a high pressure and push those clots
out of the body and that'll create
better distribution for our fluid and
better preservation in the final
[Music]
procedure this one is called a tissue
spreader so let's say you have someone
with a little extra weight and you need
to get into let's say the the meat of
their leg to gain access to their artery
this guy you can put in like this and it
spreads out all that fat any number of
Handy scissors a curve is nice sometimes
especially as you're uh cutting through
arteries or maybe other uh tissue this
is called an aneurysm hook because it's
used for separating tissue and hooking
the arteries and pulling them out where
you have access to them this is called a
Groove director I can hold this put it
into the artery and then this hard
surface in the bottom is going to open
up the artery so I can slide my other
tools right in an angular
forceps this you can actually use to
pull out clots this guy is called a
drain tube typically this end here is
going to be hooked up to another tube
that we run down the table and then this
end is going to go inside the artery one
thing that's great about a drain tube is
that we can actually control how much
blood leaves the body if we're having
drainage issues you can stop it pressure
is building in the body and then all of
a sudden you'll pull the the end and
whoop it'll come pouring out the bottom
so you want to create that pressure cuz
sometimes you need a little extra to get
into the extremities like into the toes
or the fingers something like
that cavity embalming is the second part
of preparing a body in which we want to
puncture all the hollow organs and then
drain out all the goo and nastiness that
wants to live in there so the tool we're
going to use to do that is called the
tro car the tro car
is a great big steel spear this tip is
going to puncture the organ and then
this part is actually hooked up to a
vacuum so it's going to suck all that
goo right down the drain and then the
holes that we make will actually uh
provide access points for introducing
what we call cavity fluid so involing
fluid that's made to uh kill all the
bacteria and solidify those hollow
organs so we don't have any issues down
the road this is a tro as well is
slightly different and that it doesn't
suck fluid out but puts fluid back in so
in this case we take a bottle of cavity
fluid we would actually twist it in and
attach it to the top of the tro car and
then right through that same hole we
made before we go back in all the while
gravity is actually drawing the fluid
down and inserting that from the end of
the tip back into all the holes we made
into the heart into the lungs and then
you'll go around back down into the
abdomen this is really the lower part is
where all the bacteria like to hang out
and that my friends is how you embalm a
body when I embal my first body it it is
kind of scary kind of unnerving because
it's one of those things you have to do
right the first time and you only get
one chance so if you screw up and maybe
pressure is too high and the face starts
to swell and you don't see that you've
caused a problem with Grandma or grandpa
that you can't really fix so attention
to detail is every
[Music]
welcome to the selection room if you
have a loved one that passes away odds
are good you'll end up in a room just
like this to select your funeral
merchandise when a family chooses
cremation family might want to select
and earn and these range all over the
place there are simple earns that maybe
start at $100 or less they're really
fancy maybe cast bronze ones that are
hundreds and hundreds of dollars or some
families just opt to use the container
that comes from the Crematory just a
simple plastic earn any one of those
perfectly suitable for what a family
wants to
do so one thing that can kind of be
confusing and is often used
interchangeably is the difference
between a casket and a coffin in other
parts of the world uh like in the UK for
instance they have what are called
coffins so these are what we might call
anthropoid shape so they're narrow at
the top where the head is they widen out
at the shoulders then they come back in
again towards the feet whereas caskets
are uniformly rectangular in the United
States we used almost exclusively
caskets caskets vary as widely as you
can possibly imagine we have very simple
cardboard cloth covered caskets that
might be more suitable for a simple
burial or maybe cremation and then we
have high-end caskets made from
Hardwoods like mahogany or cherry or
even bronze caskets variety is is really
the the spice of death
[Music]
here here we are in the Funeral Chapel
we've taken our dummy Mike and now we
are ready for his family to come and say
their final goodbyes this opening here
is called a cap and this is an example
of what we call a half couch casket so
you're only going to see uh from about
the midsection up you should note every
person in the casket is wearing pants
but not always
shoes when we go to close a casket um
often times I have the deceased family
around me there's a locking mechanism
under here and we're just going to
simply pull that up we'll open the
latches here at the
bottom and then with the family we'd all
grab hold we'd slowly lower the
lid and then We Say
Goodbye as a last step um I'll have you
come with me as we load the casket into
the hearse and we'll make our way to the
cemetery come
on oh this is such a cool one oh look at
the lights on the inside they're awesome
you have a great herar
Sean
so the vehicle behind me some call it a
hearse some call it a coach but in any
case it gets the deceased from point A
to point B there's some special things
about a hearse the first thing you
should know is that every single one is
custom built so there's not a single
company that makes herses right off the
line everyone is made with a normal car
cut in half extended and totally rebuilt
you do not need a special license or
anything to driver hear being built on
Lincoln and Cadillacs usually they have
nice big engines and and they go well
over 100 mph if needed on the back end
they they normally have a vinyl top at
least in the states that swooshy design
on the back is called a landow bar it's
kind of the uh the quintessential Mark
of hearse it's a Remnant from when they
used to be coaches so horse Dr carriages
and the top would pull back today we
don't have convertible herses but it's a
nice Mark when you see one you know
exactly what it is so one thing you'll
notice about a Hearst is that the door
opens really wide so when you have six
casket bears you can get nice and close
before you put the casket on the rollers
and the
rollers go all the way inside so it's a
nice smooth uh roll into the hearse when
you get the casket in
place you're going to take this
stopper put it just like this and keep
the casket so it doesn't go flying out
of the
back when I load a hearse I always go
ahead first uh the reason being when you
tilt the casket a little bit to get it
in then their feet are down and if they
slide they slide towards their feet
whereas if you flipped it around the
other way they'd be going head first and
it's awfully heavy so always the heavy
head end first and uh the feet will
follow well why don't we try loading it
up with our with our friend Mike we've
taken him from point A now let's go to
point Z and uh Sean is going to help me
here
[Music]
I so appreciate you coming with me on
this trip today through the funeral home
I hope you've learned some things and
that maybe you feel a little bit more
comfortable as you come with me on my
life with the
[Music]
Dead